Now we'll show you where Docker
really shines, by showing how
easy it is to get multiple versions
of nginx running using it.
This is where Docker adds some value.
It allows us to run
self-contained applications
that have their own versions, packaging
that includes their own dependencies.
So two versions need
different dependencies,
Docker allows us to do that by
bundling up these two containers.
Plus Docker abstracts away
the underlying OS package managers if
they may had been to learn the RPM
on Red Hat and apt-get on Debian.
We can just learn the Docker CLI.
Let's get started by installing Docker.
Now that we have Docker installed,
we are ready to work with Docker images.
You can see we don't currently have
any images installed on our system.
So let's go ahead and
get the same virgin nginx we installed
through our package manager.
This takes some time to download
the image from a repository
because we're pulling in nginx and
all of its dependencies.
So that the image can be self-contained.
We'll talk more about repositories
in the future, but for
now let's focus on images.
Now if we run the Docker images command,
you can see that we have nginx image.
And you can verify this is the same
version of nginx we installed
using the native OS package manager